before we look at this it's always
really important that we bridge new
knowledge from all knowledge right so
before we get into her like the nuts and
bolts of dividing captions I was too
quickly think about dividing whole
numbers because we've been doing that
for ages ok so right with me right
consider let's do say well so i could
just want to happen over here let's go
15 divided by 3 15 / 3 of course is come
in threes go in fun right so that's true
so what we're asking 15 / 3 and saying
five what this means is three can fit
five of them in here does that make
sense let's just drop it down right this
means that i can fit five lots of 3 into
55 watts of 3g thing okay so we know how
this works if i had 15 things mmm this
is 500 25 I've got 15 boxes here now
right how many times can I break it up
into three and I can do it one two three
four five times you're happy it's so I'm
going to take this idea go home and
think about what happens if i bring a
fraction to play right so now let's
think about hmm
to a simpler one let's go oh now I'm
this some of you know the answer you can
just jump right here that's great but I
want you to pause first and think about
how fits together with this 15 x x 3 is
5 that is how many threes i can fit here
so what is this question asked me how
could we live a life yeah perfect let's
will write that down right what this
means is this maintenance how many
hearts go into three
okay now just like before we do some
diagrams to help us right I know this is
a very simple example but that's why are
we helpful for us to draw like the
harder examples later I'd like us to
draw three boxes each one just like
these guys each one representing one
unit so if I've got 13 right so here are
my one two three units this whole set of
boxes stands for three the question is
how many halves can I get out of it
right so if it's like this you know
you've got three kit kats you want to
share with your friend anything ok I
won't at least half a kit kat like you
know I'd really like a pimp your cat but
if I get at least i'll i'll be happy so
you break every single one yeah so let's
draw our breaks there by the way you
know has anyone ever broken a bone never
broken a bone before yeah ok so can
remember when we say oh I've got a break
in my bones we have a very special
weather is it usually associate away we
call it a fracture right a fracture
because it beans braised fracture means
break which is exactly where this word
comes from you guys know my obsession
with names of things I fraction
literally means when you take some whole
things and you break it to pieces into
smaller bits so you guys can tell me how
many fractions have any components how I
got yukiko six right unless that's none
of them just so we can see what's going
on one two three four five six that's
how many halves there are in three
ok 3 / a hostage 6 or 25 Zach knitting
now hope you can see ya go yes you might
just go remember I hope you can see just
by doing that like breaking right 3
divided by a hub is actually the same as
what I get how many pieces out of 80
chica I'm getting trip is ready to you
to you to you so what I've done is the
same as saying three times to you notice
that right it's a very simple part to do
3 times 2 and 3 divided by our heart
they're actually the same thing you
notice that okay this is Patti always
work let's think about this okay one
more this is example one its revolution
its amplitude let's do one last example
devil three and then we can come with a
summary or hmm let's think that's
something to say I will do it happy 14 /
yeah I don't do peanuts ok this is
trickier it's trickier yeah again we're
going to use a picture to help us and
then see if we can come up with a rule
for this ok for let's draw our four
blocks ok so we've got our charity one
yeah okay now there are my four blocks
and I'm trying to say how many
two-thirds like that's the size of the
block of interest how many of those can
I fit into that for now just pause for a
second before we start to do this I want
you to make a prediction how many do you
think we can don't say it out just think
about it if you like this is having fun
everyone wants two thirds of a kit kat
this is how many you think about it ok
let's start to break these things up
let's try to fracture these kit kat and
see what comes one um what division
should i do for each make it count how
much should i divide one into them yep
ok I'll energy thirds for each one right
if I up and you can do this with me I
break each one into thirds like so
that's okay how many times can I get two
thirds how far all of my broken pieces
okay some of them are easy to come apart
then you can give me an answer before
you know it up let's let's go through
the process okay um maybe you want to do
some circles right so i can see right
there here's the two thirds i'm gonna
call that one I can see if I go to the
next few can I can't get one out of here
but if I go to the next one here's my
second one but now look after I've
broken off those two blocks of two
thirds you see down the bottom if I put
these guys together there's a third one
do you see it okay so i can complete
this again I should do the same thing
for the attitude right he is the fourth
one is a good point now Brad you can
tell us we have how many to thank you
much okay so 4 divided by two thirds
also equal 6 as many things but I one
not can we connect this back to over
your song dizziness when we get 3
divided by a half it was very similar to
turning the division into obligation and
then what did you hear haha and two how
are they related to each other to yogurt
okay um yeah uh hi 02 it's just 10 fancy
we can we can say that is i can write to
as a fraction I know it's a big night
but two is two over one do you agree
with that so 2 over 1 and 1 over to this
one is just like an upside down version
of that guy do you see that so what
would it look like if I try to do
something like that for this here if I
said four times what's the upside down
version of two-thirds yeah okay three
over to set of 2 over 3 okay now what is
4 times 3 over 2 how do I we've done
some multiplying fractions how do I work
this out can I've gotta be pleased to
introduce someone give me a suggestion
um I'm sure you turn the floor into a
praxis so do for over one and then you
times the one by two and in the four by
two what why I joined you to all my two
but what happens with the tough guy
whether they get what we multiply tops
yeah so you Marines not quite true it's
an odd net is multiply through so what
am I going to get as an air tali when I
when I do things once then you ready now
well yes fantastic which of course is
six right what was another way I could
have done that they don't suggest yeah
1/2 it four times three yeah very good
sir I could have done this I could have
noticed hey I can cancel things remember
we like to get small numbers if we
possibly can so if i divide these birth
I to I just end up with the two over
there which of course is still six
that's reassuring isn't so can you see
this division be right like I don't want
to have to keep on door in this diagram
especially you've got some big numbers
and some leader looking fraction so he's
my summary when i'm dividing fractions
right dividing a fraction is exactly
as multiplying by its upside-down
version do you see that to ever one is
upside down of 1 over 2 and 3 or 2 is an
upside down version of two or three now
upside down version doesn't really sound
all that fancy and technical in the
editor an official mathematical SI also
like this so we have your mathematicians
have devised a word for this instead of
upside down version because they don't
know what news is that's when our role
reversal be very very close because
reversing is a bit like integers like
going forwards and backwards and that's
not reversible I like us all to write
down this word I'm so glad you can write
it here for over one and also like you
to write a key up for three over to do
the new way I want to teach you is well
I don't have a good man soon um some of
you may have heard this word before a
similar word is reciprocate which is
like our if someone like does your favor
you will reciprocate by kind of like you
do you do them a favor like your kind of
talk here it is so a reciprocal in
mathematics it's the upside down version
that's what me we take this fraction and
turn it upside down a half turns into to
two-thirds turns into 3 over 2 and you
can do this same trick which is much
easier to do these are all quite simple
with even react or something up
ok